[Music]
hey everyone this is Jim also known as
old-school-style
and we're here on the iron Lords podcast
channel to give you a first look at a
new the distant light so let's just jump
right into it I want to go ahead and
thank resonator for providing the code
for us today
this way you all can get a first look at
this new game that's coming out I want
to add that this is just an Elfa build
this is started as a Kickstarter back in
2016 2017 so this is the first available
demo that the press has had so we're
gonna share it with you all today little
background on the game and resonator
I knew the distant light is an
independent video game being developed
by Steve Copeland and Jeff Spoonhour
they are resonator collectively Steve
and Jeff are veteran game designers who
have worked on titles such as
Borderlands 2 Bioshock 2 command &
Conquer uncharted golden abyss that's
one game Star Wars Empire at war Saints
rows 1 through 4 Lord of the Rings
battle for middle-earth SpecOps the line
and many many more a new is a
single-player open-world action and
adventure game for PCs and consoles that
will appeal to fans of platforming
combat exploration and visual
storytelling in game you are a child
with limited resources waking up on a
distant alien moon 20 light-years from
Earth you must carry out a mission of
critical importance and you have several
mysteries to solve make your way through
a dangerous alien world seek out
game-changing equipment upgrades and
vehicles to expand your options for
combat and exploration
some key gameplay features that will be
in the final build explore a huge
diverse open game world unlock the
powers of your home ship collect upgrade
and master game changing weapons and
equipment pilot powerful machines and
vehicles navigate dynamic harsh surface
conditions to discover rare creatures in
hidden secrets solve the mystery of your
missing copilot save a dying earth so
let's talk about the gameplay I gotta
tell you for an alpha it was a pretty
damn pretty damn fun kind of start out
waking up in a pod and and you just kind
of go from there there's not a lot of
room for exploring it kind of puts put
you in that little alleyway that you
gotta follow this specific route in
order to move on to progress through the
game overall though it was it was fun it
was enjoyable graphic wise I like the
style kind of reminds me and and this is
just me kind of reaching way back in the
day it really reminds me a lot of the
stop animation that they use used to use
back in the early earlier games before
graphics actually became a thing but it
was fun I like how it has the the layer
effect where the camera pulls out and
kind of zooms back in depending on what
you do infer action it worked out well
with this right now the demo itself runs
about 20 to 30 minutes depending on how
much you want to kind of kill everything
or try to explore I went through it
trying to check everything see if there
was anything else other than the linear
line they put me on and there really
isn't you do get to upgrade to a
different gun you get a shield
you do get to take on a Mac I guess
would be the term I would use but you do
get to drive one you take on some
interesting creatures you get to drive a
an ATV that launches Rockets so they
they give you a little taste of
everything in this demo performance-wise
there really wasn't many buggy options I
had to restart the game a couple of
times as the a mean option within the
game kind of locked up and I could only
shoot left to right I couldn't shoot up
or down or anything but to me that's
expected I don't expect perfection on
something like this but I would say I
would like to see definitely a longer
demo and I'm looking forward to
hopefully seeing something from them
a little bit more robust but if you're
trying to get an idea of what an idea
out there I should say of what your game
is going to do what what is going to
look like you really can't ask for much
more than this they did an excellent job
so far the game is seems to be
progressing well I don't really have any
complaints about it but I also went in
with expectations that it's an l4 and
there's gonna be a lot more that's gonna
change within the game so good job
resonator you you guys I think you guys
were on track for a really really
interesting game would I put it in a
platformer category right now probably
but I just I don't know if it's gonna
stay that way or not hopefully it'll uh
it'll get a little bit more open-world
II but not too much that it becomes
overwhelming but this is our first look
on a new the distant light hopefully
y'all enjoyed the video if you did go
ahead and hit that like button otherwise
we will see you in the next first look
video
you